Speaker 1: So I want to follow up with
you today. On April 1st, the first day
of April New Month about what's going on with
radical Republican Trump is Congressman Matt
Gaetz. Matt Gaetz recently appeared on the Tucker
Carlson Show and announced that he is vindicated.
And I was thinking, Vince, what are you talking
about? Vindicated? You're under a very serious
investigation in which you may be charged.
Now there are some who have already sort of
moved on and are assuming that because Matt Gaetz
hasn't already been charged, he's not going to be
charged. And remember, the possible crimes and
charges have a large range up to it, including
child sex trafficking, sex trafficking of a minor
sex trafficking of a minor across state lines.
But needless to say, for some reason, he thinks
that he's been vindicated. And here he is talking
to Tucker Carlson about it.
Speaker 2: A year ago today,
three hundred and sixty five days that the Justice
Department leaked the story to the New York Times
that it caught our attention immediately.
They told the Times they were investigating
Congressman Matt Gaetz, Republican of Florida, for
a very serious crime under-aged sex trafficking.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 2: So Gates made an
appearance on this show, which turned out to be
one of the weirdest interviews we've ever done.
Speaker 1: He tried it. True.
Speaker 2: He has not been on Fox
News since that day. But we did notice since we've
been sort of following it. Matt Gaetz was never
charged with anything. So how is that? The Judge
Department calls New York Times and says you're
a sex criminal. And then a year later, you're not
charged with anything. So we thought it'd be worth
inviting Congressman Matt Gaetz back on the show
to ask for an update. And here he is here. So much
for coming on. So actually, you were described in
the New York Times by the Justice Department as a
felony sex criminal. Have you been charged? Do
you expect to be charged for felony sex crimes?
No, this was an operation to destroy me, to
harm my family, to hinder my ability to serve
the district and the movement that I represent
in Congress. And we all know there's a pipeline
of leaks and lies that flow from the Justice
Department to the mainstream media, the New
York Times in particular. And that's not even a
Partizan criticism of the Biden administration
that happened during the Trump administration
as well. We saw it during the Russia hoax.
But the most important update, the most important
thing that's happened since our last on our
discussion, someone has been indicted and has
pled guilty to trying to shake down my family
based on this pile of lies. And so I'm not going
to allow it to hinder me. I'm going to continue
the important work that I do here in the Congress
for my constituents. Yeah. So I'm not going to ask
any questions about your personal life because
it's not my business. It's really simple. If
you committed a crime, let them charge you and
they have it and they've smeared your name again,
your profile. It's your business.
Speaker 1: Whether you committed
a crime or not is everybody's business
Speaker 2: and you have it and there's
one to ask you one more time. Crisply and clearly.
Do you expect to be charged for the crimes
of which they've accused? You know, that would
be a travesty. I'm innocent. I have maintained
my innocence. I have been entirely consistent on
this fact, and each and every day the lies about
me unravel and are debunked and the things I've
said. And admittedly, it's pretty wild to come on
your show and say that my family's being shaken
down for $25 million by some fraudsters, some
with connections to the intelligence community
and the Department of Justice. But in fact,
someone has pled guilty to just that.
So I feel vindicated each and every day.
Speaker 1: So he's vindicated. Now notice
a lot of the things that aren't said there.
Tucker didn't ask, Have you been cleared? Because
the answer is he hasn't been cleared. That's
number one. It's also important to mention none
of the claims reported about Gates have been
debunked at this point in time. He's just not been
charged yet. He may not be charged. I'm completely
open to that possibility. But Tucker didn't ask,
Have you been cleared? Because the answer is no.
The the thing that he was accused of doing
at one point, he claimed he didn't even know
the woman in question. We now have a paper trail
where we know that Venmo was actually used to get
money through an intermediary to the woman, he
claimed never to have met, so that has not been
debunked. In fact, that's been confirmed. And none
of the actual claims to date have actually been
shown to be untrue. Also remember just as a
reminder about the weirdness of the story.
In that weird interview a year ago, I remember
I was on vacation when this broke and I was on
my phone going, What the hell was Matt Gates
talking about? Matt Gates appeared with Tucker
in that weirdest interview we've ever done,
and he almost like implicated Tucker by saying,
You were there with me and had dinner
with one of the people I was with. This
was one of the strangest moments I've ever seen.
Speaker 2: And I only know what I've read in The
New York Times. I can say that actually, you and
I went to dinner about two years ago. Your wife
was there and I brought a friend of mine. You'll
remember her. And she was actually threatened by.
The FBI told that if she wouldn't cop to the fact
that somehow I was involved in some pay for play
scheme that she could face trouble. And so I do
believe that there are people at the Department
of Justice who are trying to smear me, you
know, providing for flights and hotel rooms
for people that you're dating who are of legal
age is not a crime. And I'm just troubled that
the lack of any sort of legitimate investigation
into me would then commute would then convert
into this extortion attempt. I don't remember
the woman you're speaking of or the context
at all, honestly.
Speaker 1: But what,
if anything, could accurately be described as
Kafka esque? I think it would be that. So listen,
yes, get the truth, as Gates has not been charged,
but he has not been cleared and the assertions
Gates has made, many of those have been proven
to be false. I don't know this woman, actually,
you do, and you did send her money supposedly
for tuition and books, but you did send her money
and the investigation is ongoing.
But what a what a bizarre situation